let's talk about some demons because
i wonder it's okay there's like deep
work
which uh and uh the
the world without email books that to me
symbolize
the life i i want to live okay
and then there is i'm like despite
appearances
an adult at this point and this is the
life i
actually live and i
it's i'm in constant chaos you said you
don't like that anxiety i hate it too
but it seems like i'm always in it it's
a giant
mess it's it's like it it's almost like
whenever i establish
whenever i have successful processes for
doing deep work i'll add stuff on top of
it just to introduce the chaos
yeah and and like i don't want to yeah
but you know it's so
you have to look in the mirror at a
certain point and you have to say like
who the hell am i like i keep doing this
is this something that's fundamental to
who i am or do i really need to fix this
what's the chaos right now like i've
seen your video about like your routine
it seemed very
structured and deep in fact i was really
envious of it so like what's the chaos
now that's not in that video many of
those sessions go way longer
i don't get enough sleep yeah and then i
the main introduction of chaos
is it's taking on too many things on the
to-do list
it's i mean i suppose it's the problem
that everybody deals with was just
saying
not saying no but it's not like i have
trouble saying no it's that there's so
much cool [ __ ] in my life yeah okay
listen i've
there's nothing i love more in this
world than the boston dynamics
robots yeah and they're giving me spot
so there's enough to do what am i going
to say no yeah and so they're giving me
spot and i want to do some computer
vision stuff for
for the hell of it okay so that's not
what to do item
and then you go to texas for a while and
there's texas and everything's happening
with all the interesting people down
there
and then there's surprises right there
power outage in texas there's constant
changes to plans and all those kinds of
things
and you sleep less and then there's
personal stuff like just you know
people in your life sources of stress
all those kinds of things and
but it does feel like if i'm just being
introspective
that i bring it on to myself i suppose a
lot of people do this kind of thing
yes is they
they flourish under pressure yeah and i
wonder if that
um if that's just the hack i've
developed as a habit
early on in life that needs you need to
let go of
you need to fix but it's all interesting
things
yeah that's that's that's interesting
yeah because these are all interesting
things
well one of the things you talked about
and deep work which is like really
important is like
having an end to the day yeah like
putting it down
yeah like that i don't think i've ever
done that in my life
yeah well see i started doing that early
because uh
i got married early so you know i didn't
have a real job i was a grad student but
my wife had a real job
and so i just figured i should do my
work
when she's at work because you know hey
when when work's over she'll be home and
i don't want i don't want to be
you know on campus or whatever and so
real early on i just got in that habit
of
this is when you know this is when
you're in work and then when i was a
postdoc
which is kind of an easy job right i put
artificial
i was like i want to train i think when
i'm a professor it's going to be busier
because there's
demands that professors have beyond
research and so as a postdoc i added
artificial large time consuming things
into the middle of my day i'd basically
exercise for two hours in the middle of
the day
and do all this this productive
meditation and stuff like this
while still maintaining the nine to five
so it's like okay i want to get really
good at
putting artificial constraints on so
that i stay i didn't want to get
flabby when my job was easy so that when
i became a professor
and now all of that's paying off because
i have a ton of kids so
so now i don't really have a choice
that's what's probably keeping me away
from cool things
is i just don't have time to do them and
then after a while people
you know stop bothering well but that
you know but that's how you have a
successful life otherwise you're going
to
it's too easy to then go into the full
hunter s thompson
yeah like to where no nobody
wants nobody functional wants to be in
your vicinity
like you're driving you attract the
people
that have a similar behavior pattern as
you
yeah so if you if you live in chaos
you're going to attract chaotic people
and then and it becomes like this uh
self uh fulfilling prophecy
yeah and it feels like i'm not bothered
by it
but i guess this is all coming around to
exactly what you're saying which is like
i think one of the big hacks for
productive people that i've met
is to get married and have kids
honestly it's it's very perhaps
counter-intuitive
yeah but it gets it's like the ultimate
timetable enforcer yeah it enforces a
lot of timetables
uh though it has a huge project kids
have a huge productivity hit those he
got away
you